BETTERHELP:
If you spend enough time on YouTube, I’m
sure you’ve heard of BetterHelp.
They’re the online therapy platform that’s
supposed to help people work through the darkest
portions of their lives.
And for the most part, they do a pretty good
job.
They have managed to grow a massive network
of 23,000 fully certified, experienced therpaists
who serve over 2.5 million people.
And it seems that almost all of these users
are pretty happy given that they have over
a 100,000 reviews on the app store with an
average rating of 4.8.
But, it’s not all good news.
You see, while BetterHelp’s overall goals
and intentions may be pure, they’re behavior
has largely been influenced by the need to
maximize profits and achieve global domination
as the go to mental therapy platform.
For example, you’ve probabaly heard of doctor-patient
privilege.
This is one of the most important aspects
of therapy.
More times than not, people visit therapists
to open up about topics that their ashamed
about or embarrassed about.
Doctor-patient privilege is what encourages
these people to share these vulnerable moments
and get the help they need.
As such, protecting doctor-patient privilege
is of utmost importance for most clinics and
psychiatrists but this doesn’t seem to be
the case at BetterHelp.
In fact, BetterHelp has repeatedly sold sensitive
data to Facebook, Snapchat, Pinterest and
other such platforms over the past several
years.
But the worst part though was how they addressed
the situation when the FTC confronted them
about this practice earlier this year.
The normal response would’ve been to either
deny that they were selling this data or to
issue a public apology for their behavior.
But BetterHelp actually had the audacity to
claim that yes, they were selling data, but
no it’s not wrong.
They would write off the situation as quote
“industry-standard practice...
routinely used by some of the largest health
providers, health systems, and healthcare
brands."
It seems that BeterHelp has made their position
clear and that’s just the tip of the iceberg.
So, join me as we take a look at the dark
side of BetterHelp.
SELLING OUT:
Usually, when we’re talking about data privacy,
it’s more of an ethical question as opposed
to a legal one.
For example, Google and Meta’s data collection
is questionable from an ethical perspective
but not from a legal one.
After all, they lay out exactly what they’re
gonna collect in their privacy policy and
you basically have to sign off this agreement
to even use most of these platforms.
With BetterHelp on the other hand, that’s
not the case.
Now, I’m sure that if you really dig into
their fine print, somewhere it acknowledges
that they may share your data, but throughout
the platform, they constantly reassure customers
that privacy is a top priority.
“Rest assured – any information provided
in this questionnaire will stay private between
you and your counselor.”
Messages with your Therapist are not shared
with any Third Party, and your live sessions
are not recorded.
We also do not share when you send a message,
or have a session with your Therapist, with
any Third Party.
This last statement must’ve been a new addition
because they used to do exactly this.
Back in 2020, an investigation revealed that
BetterHelp was allegedly sharing the metadata
of therapist conversations with Facebook.
Facebook was being alerted everytime a user
opened BetterHelp and sent a message.
This meant that Facebook was essentially getting
a full log of when users were having therapy
sessions, where they were attending sessions
from, and for how long.
When confronted about this, BetterHelp would
simply decline to answer.
You would think that they would stop selling
data after this confrontation but it seems
that they may have actually doubled down.
According to an FTC report that came out in
March of 2023, BetterHelp allegedly used a
wide variety of tactics to share the health
information of over 7 million consumers with
Facebook, Snapchat, and Pinterest.
They even allegedly shared data collected
from health questionnaires which included
questions like these.
Are you experiencing overwhelming sadness,
grief, or depression?
Have you had thoughts that you would be better
off not alive?
And, have you taken medication or been in
therapy before.
Why would BetterHelp share this data you ask?
Well, so that these users could be retargeted
with BetterHelp ads.
According to the FTC complaint, “Using this
health information for advertising, [BetterHelp]
has brought in hundreds of thousands of new
users, resulting in millions of dollars in
additional revenue.”
This by the way seems to be working out really
well for BetterHelp as they just had their
first billion dollar year.
And the fine for all of this is just a mere
$7.8 million which will be used to refund
affected users.
As we previously mentioned, BetterHelp never
admitted guilt claiming that this was just
standard industry practice and unfortunately,
they’re actually right.
Around the same time that BetterHelp was exposed,
it came out that another online therapy platform,
Cerebral, had done the same thing.
They had shared the private health information,
including metal health assessemnts, of 3.1
million patients with Facebook, Google, and
TikTok.
And according to a report from Mozilla, it’s
the same case with most other online therapy
platforms as well.
As such, the FTC is more concerned about reforming
the entire industry as opposed to just fining
BetterHelp for as much as possible.
And in that vein, they’ve proposed a couple
of new guidelines and reforms.
MENTAL HEALTH REFORM:
The FTC has proposed a total of 6 new reforms
that BetterHelp must abide by and other platforms
should probably follow as well.
The first reform is expanding the definition
of health information.
One of the main reasons that these platforms
are able to get away with sharing so much
information about users is because a lot of
like email addresses, ip addresses, and meta
data isn’t technically considered health
information.
But, the FTC is arguing that context counts.
Sure, an email address may not usually be
considered health information, but when a
consumer enters an email address on a mental
health platform, it’s a different story.
That email address suddenly becomes personally
identifiable information that this user may
need therapy.
So, moving forward, these platforms should
treat auxiliary information as health information
as well.
The second reform centers on impleneitng policies,
practices, and procedures to protect health
information.
This one is pretty straight forward, the FTC
claims that BetterHelp doesn’t have written
policies and procedures for protecting the
privacy of health information.
They also fell short on properly training
and supervising employees that had access
to health information.
As such, platforms must implement the required
policies and procedures but more importantly,
platforms must get affirmative express consent
before sharing user data with 3rd parties.
Speaking of transparency, the FTC has also
ruled that these platforms must ditch their
deceptive designs.
One of the main reasons that people trust
these platforms so easily is because the platforms
make statements like this.
“We never sell or rent any information you
share with us.”
Reading this, it’s natural to think that
your private data is safe.
It’s not until you read the fine print that
you actually understand what’s going on.
And given that virtually no one reads the
fine print, almost no one knows what’s going
on until something like this report comes
out.
Considering this, the FTC has required platforms
to be more transparent about their data collection
and sharing.
And to BetterHelp’s credit, it seems like
they’ve already implemented this.
If you go to BetterHelp’s website now, you’re
immediately greeted with this banner on the
bottom that admits that they collect and share
data with Meta and TikTok including personally
identifiable information.
Ideally, they wouldn’t share this data at
all but atleast now, they’re being transparent
about it.
Moving onto the 4th reform, the FTC is ordering
platforms to be more transparent about how
encryption doesn’t necessarily protect privacy.
Here’s the thing, when people here that
their personal data is being encrypted, they
automatically equate that to their personal
data being protected.
But, this is a rather misleading statement
because if you give Facebook the encrypted
data along with the keys to decrypt it, while
the data is still being kept secure, it’s
not exactly being kept private.
Next up, the 5th reform is pretty straight
forward.
The FTC wants these platforms to play a more
active role in monitoring what data their
ad partners actually collect and share.
And finally, the last reform prevents platforms
from misleadingly using certain seals in their
advertising material.
For example, BeterHelp allegedly used the
term HIPAA throughout their marketing material,
something that likely conveyed that some sort
of 3rd party or government agency had reviewed
and certified the platform when that wasn’t
the case.
Honestly, all of these reforms are great steps
forward in making online therapy a truly safe
and private space.
But, I think this still leaves one overarching
question unanswered.
Should we even be promoting online therapy?
THE PROBLEM WITH ONLINE THERAPY:
It’s no wonder why online therapy has exploded
in popularity especially with the pandemic.
People like the convenience of being able
to talk to a professional from the comfort
of their home.
But the simple reality is that online therapy
doesn’t stack up to in person therapy and
I don’t think that’s really a controversial
statement.
The in person connection is simply on a different
level which generally leads to far better
results but there’s more to consider than
just results.
One of the biggest shortfalls of online therapy
platforms like BetterHelp is that they don’t
accept health insurance.
This means that the entire cost of the platform
and therapist is coming out of your pocket.
To BetterHelp’s credit, they have kept pricing
quite affordable all things considered.
Only $60 to $90 per week.
But with that being said, if you leverage
your health insurance and go to an in person
clinic, you should be able to get a far higher
quality of care for the same out of pocket
cost.
Also, speaking about the quality of care,
in person clinics will almost always have
higher quality care.
This isn’t a knock on BetterHelps therapists.
I’m sure there’s a good number of highly
qualified therapists on BetterHelp, but the
key thing to note is that therapists on BetterHelp
are psychologists, not psychiatrists.
In fact, BetterHelp does not even currently
support psychiatrists.
This might sound like a novel difference but
it’s not.
Psychiatrists are actual medical professionals
who went to medical school and are cerfitied
to diagnose illness and prescribe medication.
Psychologists on the other hand are more or
less just professionals that you can talk
to.
Again, I’m sure there’s plenty of highly
qualified psychologists but if you need serious
help including diagnosis, prescriptions, and
professional medical advice, a psychiatrist
is who you need to see.
But, I bet most BetterHelp users aren’t
even aware of this distinction or how BetterHelp
doesn’t have psychiatrists which brings
us back to really the core issue at hand which
is the commercialization of therapy.
While platforms like BetterHelp may have the
bets of intentions, they’re also trying
to maximize profits.
In an industry like social media, search,
or email, it’s whatever.
But, when it comes to mental health, this
becomes a lot more dangerous.
In fact, most of BetterHelp’s shady activity
can be attributed to their profit motive.
Why does BetterHelp share personal user data
with Meta?
Well, to reach as many people as possible
and make as much money as possible.
Why does BetterHelp have arguably misleading
promotional material?
Well, to reach as many people as possible
and make as much money as possible.
Why do BetterHelp users not know the difference
between psychologists and psychitraists?
Well, because in BetterHelp’s pursuit of
reaching as many users as possible and making
as much money as possible, talking about services
that they don’t offer isn’t exactly in
their best interest.
So, why is BetterHelp dangerous?
Well, because they’re commercializing therapy
like never before and that naturally comes
along with a bunch of side effects.
Someone else who has sold their soul is Skillshare.
Check out this video to learn more.